whack jobs and protests
well folks looks like the circus is in
town again
[Music]
[Applause]
apparently the Ringling Brothers have
decided reminds me of my days at Boston
Latin they've been holding open casting
calls and select cities throughout the
country and I gotta say I'm quite
impressed with the new breed of talent
they've acquired they got puppet shows
celebrity appearances Sheldon from The
Big Bang Theory will be doing autographs
they even have musical performances
I just thank God for abortion
this is what I talk about when I say
it's not pro-choice it's pro-abortion
it's crazy if you followed the leftist
ideologies strictly your life would be
hell your life would legit be hell if
you followed all the stuff that they
tell you to do pump your body up with
birth control pills if you have any
problems take antidepressants get
abortions when you have babies if you
don't feel comfortable don't take
self-accountability yeah no personal
responsibility everything is about
listen to spaces wear your mask wear
your mask if you just listen to them
your life would be toast just completely
protect yourself from any kind of stress
or any kind of difficulty and then never
grow and never be able to actually
handle anything because you can't
protect yourself from difficulty you
can't Shield yourself from life it's
crazy
here's the head recruiter
which is the just the
for a second because just like the thank
God for abortion if you had any God in
your life you wouldn't be thanking him
for abortion you would be thanking him
for life and for and for that's that's
like go to Straight to Hell be thanking
him for the beauty of the people in your
life not thanking them that not thanking
him for the ability to the free will to
kill babies it's just weird yeah it is
ironic they don't even understand that
Haram
oh sure what's the requirement no soul
that shouldn't be too hard to find just
look into people's eyes you can tell if
it's been taken if you see a wide-eyed
glazed over hypnotic gaze you've got
yourself a prospect and soon your
thoughts shall all be mine
[Music]
as you are told that's right folks
there's no show like it bring the kids
the performers love them
so keep your eyes peeled everyone
they're coming to a city near you
I like to keep your laws off our bodies
and then they overturn Roe v Wade which
was exactly that keeping laws off your
bodies what was um keeping federal laws
off your bodies and making it into the
states which in which case you actually
have a lot more power to make a decision
on how your state will handle it and
they they got what they wanted and they
realized that it wasn't what they wanted
so I put the armpit here bro I don't get
that I don't know that's you know what
that is a whole separate issue I told
you about the time where I don't care
about armpit her and there was this like
10 out of 10 girl but she had a full
pits full armpit hair we were hanging
out at her house while me and my friends
and her friends and she laid down on the
bed and went like that and we were just
like
yeah that's not for us
you don't ask her about it it's weird
well it is to us I just asked but it's
not to everybody what the [ __ ] do you
like it or not
speaking of Sideshow remember this guy
oh my God look at this dude I like it
this dude looks straight at Game of
Thrones
look at this
rare footage of Johnny Bravo's son
waiting at the airport look how out of
breath he is
choosing the right face to make in your
selfies must be exhausting look how fast
he went through three different face
alterations he looks like he belongs in
a 20 20. this is expert level
influencing we just doesn't he oh that
was such a mom joke but yeah I hate
watching that stuff I hate watching
people even like read Snapchat I know
I'm embarrassed for him just witnessed
here folks you got the traditional
portrait look you got the and thinking
of trying it in my butt but I'm nervous
look then you got the classic duck lips
three rapid fire selfies all within a
two-second window just an incredible
display of skill this guy's like a
Modern Day Cowboy the fastest selfie
Slinger in the west meanwhile this
girl's horrified
yeah and you got Jack White back there
just came out of solitary confinement
see the look on her face that's the look
your friends and family make when your
selfies show up in their feed in all
seriousness I know you're trying really
hard to be cool but someone in your
support system needs to step in and tell
you the truth it doesn't matter how many
holes you have in your jeans how many
tips of hair you frost or how many times
you wear sunglasses indoors as long as
you're doing that no one will ever look
at you and say now that guy looks cool
never it'll never happen never no amount
of duck lips selfies or photos with your
mouth half open will ever lead to
admiration you know what it does lead to
though people filming you and uploading
it to the internet which leads to people
sending it to me and that's not
something to strive for
[Laughter]
that's something yeah I do hope that
everyone who's listening isn't that's
brutal losing like that like let's let's
have if you're still out here snapping
people non-stop snapping people pictures
of your face you gotta get a life G
let's just try to have a little bit more
depth than that and what successful
people or all that but sit around and
snap pictures of their face all day
that's like some broken [ __ ] right there
I just think it's sad like the constant
cry for attention makes me I don't it's
not even like attention I don't know
it's just like mind filling garbage just
like scrolling on Instagram or Tick Tock
it's just nothing it's just consuming
your brain and what it could be thank
you guys so much for watching make sure
to like subscribe I think only like 10
of you guys that watch are subscribed so
make sure to hit the button what what
and follow me on Instagram at sunnyfast
doing a bunch of giveaways and [ __ ]
there follow me on Instagram for
pictures of Sunny Fest and the dog what
do you care about the pictures of the
dog
[Music]
foreign
[Music]